so two of the things that you pointed
out as uh programming choices
one was that anything with donald trump
or response to donald trump rated better
and so uh you or
just everybody every cable news outlet
covered everything trump did
during his 2016 run and then that became
true obviously when he was president
and then the inverse of that was that if
there was something kind of educational
or scientific
or deeper then it would be less
appealing or wouldn't rate as well and
so you want to
wound up with like a bias towards uh
trump all the time
and less about for example what a public
health
official or scientist was saying yeah
yeah
um and initially when the
pandemics started they
are professional journalists and they
kicked into gear just like they should
and they were
trying to get the information they could
from
scientists and doctors and front-line
workers
and um developed a special
um dr zeke emanuel was
you know on once a week to cover
you know focus on issues related to
covid
and after a number of weeks they
discovered that that wasn't rating well
so
then it got kind of you know started on
monday tuesday and they pushed it to a
friday because that's a day that
they don't care as much about ratings
because that's
for our own program for msnbc's or
last words and programming needs that it
wasn't
as important and then it slowly just
kind of fizzled out and died
and it was because it wasn't rating well
and
and then you could see the coverage when
they were
would do a coveted segment it really was
about
just the politics um and they
would have on science reporters or
correspondents
but they were you know pushing them
trying to get them to talk more about
the politics and the actual science and
it was through a time when there were a
lot you know there i mean there's still
lots of information coming out all the
time about the
about the the virus and vaccines and
what we know and what we don't know
and that all of that was
you know they would try to get to it if
they could or
it just wasn't kind of the top line it
was something that was thrown in maybe
as a you know an afterthought
um that all of that information really
got pushed to the wayside and
they focused much more on the politics
and it was you know the
uh trump attacking the blue state
governors
or you know what trump you know what
dumb thing trump said or didn't say or
didn't do
um it really focused on that and i
understand there's a time and a place
for that but it was just dominated
everything that drove me crazy on the
trail too
where it was always like trump's stupid
or inflammatory comment of the day and
then even
like i'd be running for president in
iowa in new hampshire and they'd be like
trump said this what do you think of
that and i'm just like are you kidding
me
really yeah and yeah yeah that
um that same idea was pervasive
throughout the end
you know it was the last election cycle
as well um
the democratic primary process you know
if there was a personality
dispute that got way more attention than
any interesting
policy conversation and i think there
were lots of interesting policy
conversations we could have had and you
know
um the ideas that you had being the
start of it um
uh but then you know when it came down
to the general and it was biden versus
trump and you know every almost every
single
i i know that they tried to to focus on
biden
when they could but it always turned
into a segment about trump
you know they don't want to talk about
anything that is negative towards
democrats because that was bad for the
msnbc audience
and the same thing you know applied to
the democratic primaries as well
you don't there just wasn't a full
discussion
that ultimately benefits everyone so
i think i might have been part of that
or non part of that
yeah i know i know this is not exactly
an unbiased
audience i'm talking to right now but
yeah no no i mean
again like this this to me is more of
like a systemic um
uh no it is for sure and it
uh yeah i saw it happen i watched it in
2016 and so that you know when everybody
was
i'm sorry um everyone was shocked that
hillary didn't do better than she did i
i was frustrated because i was like no
there were there were polling numbers
out that showed you know enthusiasm for
her you know
that were concerning and you know that
msnbc wasn't covering that so that
liberal audience didn't
neces you know necessarily well that's
rough you know like that there were
actually some
uh numbers that cut the other way that
weren't covered i mean that that's
that's actually new to me
relatively speaking maybe everyone knows
that already i i was
angry almost every day in those meetings
through and it it
did it was not pleasant because i
i was at a point where i i could i i
mean i never really bite my tongue
anyway but i
i just could not believe that they were
making decisions about
you know economic poli segments and oh
that's not gonna
you might not the date i gave my
resignation they cancelled
an economic segment because quota wasn't
gonna rate and they filled it with some
other like
um you know not a serious
segment and um
[Music]
i you know between the pandemic
and i i frankly had issues with how they
were covering the george floyd stuff
um the protests uh
again you know
the way that they covered the protest
they they
wanted conflict and they put the
correspondence on the ground
in a way that they they even if nothing
was happening they wanted it to seem
like something was happening
and if there was a car that was on fire
they're gonna play that video
over and over again meanwhile 95
of the protests were peaceful but i've
been in the control room
going back to 2015 and and the black
lives matters protest then
people um they would monitor
all of those protests they'd have
cameras and choppers you know they're
monitoring
the protests and unless it turned
violent they would not quote take it
live
you know they they wouldn't show that
peaceful protest because nothing was
happening
according to them you know it was it was
boring and it wouldn't make good tv
so that um that is the type of thing
that
kind of got to me um through the george
floyd
um coverage uh there were there were
other
elements there were there were um points
about the
uh election and election security
those stories kept getting sidelined
they were not covering them they'd
you know i i was trying to get them to
cover the issues you know how
how were you going to have a safe
election you know with covid and you
know there were lots of groups working
on it
they um it was really really really
difficult to get them to cover that
[Music]
there was
there were opportunities when trump went
to tulsa
there were opportunities to to talk
about some of the
kind of painful history in this country
um
it was would have been very easy to
discuss
um the history in tulsa and the tulsa
riots or
juneteenth and what is all be
you know what is behind that and why
it's so meaningful to the
african-american community
and you can trace the anger from those
events
to george floyd it would have been it
wouldn't have taken very long at all
but there were there was there was um a
history there that i didn't know
and i know a lot of smart people and
journalists didn't know
and it was a perfect opportunity to to
share that and it helps
the nation understand you know what is
happening other than just
you know people are angry and and
looting the local walmarts
one thing that a producer a friend of
yours said that really
um seemed telling was look people come
to us for comfort like they don't see us
as the news
i i thought that was incredible and and
there is something fundamental about
uh two different purposes one would be
i'm going to edify and inform
and so i'm going to serve you some stuff
that might be
not that scintillating it might be kind
of boring it's like broccoli as
programming
and then there's this other direction
that it's like i'm entertainment
like i'm going to have a certain patter
and rhythm and characters and something
that you can cheer or boo
right yeah and that was in one of our uh
uh planning meetings so that was a
senior producer and
um it's definitely something that
you know stood out and something i
remembered because you're abdicating
your role as a journalist and that's
it's confusing because
otherwise it kind of looks like a
newscast you know you have an anchor
sitting at a desk
with you know you know the tv over his
shoulder
and you're covering things that are in
the news
and so the audience uh you know i
realized that you know they
there's there's an awareness that msnbc
is um
uh more opinionated than the straight
you know 6 p.m newscast but at the same
time
they're they they play it both ways
so that's what i think is really
dangerous when it
looks like something that should be
reliable but
it it isn't really then that's that's
to me where the problem comes in i'm
pretty sure news is in the name
somewhere
[Laughter]
you know like there's somewhere in there
like there's the word news
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you